I think you guys are gonna enjoy this
one I think you're gonna enjoy this one
and while part of it may be what you
think
I think there's going to be a surprise
too WB uh first off reached out a couple
weeks ago and asked if we would like
collector's edition and I said why sure
I would love one thank you very much for
considering us
however I believe there are some
additional items in here as well so I'm
expecting a collector's edition I took a
little peek and just confirmed like okay
that's what this is
but there is more than a Collector's
Edition in here all right so now fragile
Handle With Care we have this right here
which at first I thought oh this is the
collector's edition so we have this box
here something something in here
let's set that to the side for now
then this one is more recognizable here
we have a copy of the Collector's
Edition on the PlayStation 5. so I'm
gonna sit this the mystery I mean look
at that it is
it is pretty thick it's almost as big as
the collector's edition so we're gonna
sit that to the side all right and then
we have the PS5 collectors
right here we go so we go ahead and
slide this off
and let's see on the back you have live
the unwritten so yeah Steelcase and the
full game for PS5 I'm curious to see if
it comes with the regular case and the
steel case so when Chandler did the
unboxing it was only the steel case but
they've always showed it with that box
as well then you have the floating wand
with the book that's the big attraction
the box of course the dark arts pack and
then the Kelpie rope dark arts Garrison
hat as well I'm really curious to see
this this wand
the ancient magic wand oh yes it does
come with the Box let's go dude I was
really hoping that it would alright so a
copy of the Hogwarts Legacy
Deluxe
it's my first time actually holding a
game box it's my first time holding the
Hogwarts Legacy game box dude
let's go
very cool I'm glad it came with that all
right so there okay that is nice that is
a nice steel case I gotta say
gotta say that will look very nice on
the Shelf here Hogwarts crest on the
front with the never tickle a sleeping
Dragon see if we can hold that up a
little bit closer
all right so here's what we have you
have Hogwarts up here in the top left
you got the Black Lake Forbidden Forest
over here hogsmeade over here and then
on the back you've got like portkey
games
the mysterious figure here
the mysterious figure the ancient magic
symbol which we all know and are
familiar with at this point let's hold
it a little bit closer there
so you guys can see it
there you go and then I mean just to
kind of compare it
size so you guys can get a like I felt
whenever I opened up this Hammer the
hammer is like huge so it is about
a little bit shorter than the hammer
or wider I guess
the Hammer's a little bit wider when you
stretch them across like this yeah so
that is the base
and then let's get the wand out let's
check out the wand and then don't forget
don't forget we still have the mystery
box
the mystery box we knew like the
collector's edition we knew about the
other stuff is a mystery all right so
you plug it in looks like on the top
side
right there is where the plug goes
and we have the ancient magic wand
yeah somebody was asking so we're not
we're not really spoiling story stuff
but yeah this is the wand
that comes into play late in the game
late in the game right here it is oh my
goodness dude
that kind of freaked me out a little bit
man it just like instantly
pulled it over there oh my goodness okay
it's like flipping it over wow okay I
feel
was not expecting that oh yeah so this
is like the sheet to line it up right
here
all right so Black Lake
Black Lake
all right there we go it's lined up
right there
okay so all right so it looks like I
mean definitely this is the right
direction
the handle over here on this side
and then here's a little star right here
like there's where it's showing us the
star
it just keeps like
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
there it is dude
there it is
[Music]
we got it oh wow it's pointing at me now
pointing at me don't anyone panic
if it snaps into place somewhere I'm
gonna try and see can you actually move
the book
oh that's crazy you can all right we're
gonna slide it just ever so slightly
over here to the left the mystery box
ladies and gentlemen there was another
very large
mystery item inside
very large Okay so
all right it's like a giant piece of
foam here
I think it's supposed to open up like
this though
oh my goodness
wow look at that dude
okay so yes we have
the art book over here on this side
and then four house hold on dude that's
those are like actual patches four house
patches
hold on let me see if I can lift it out
of here I think I can
oh yes perfect
look at that dude
if you guys can get a little bit all
right where are the gryffindors at
Gryffindor
and then let's see our oh hold on the
mic's in the way
ravenclaws where are you at ravenclaws
and then we have our slytherins
and then we have
Hufflepuff I mean you could take them
out
like this is like a little foam backing
but I think I might want to just keep
them in here maybe hang this up
somewhere you have some room above here
oh dude that's actually sick wow okay
that is very cool and then the art book
here
which many of you guys may have a copy
of this
the art and making of Hogwarts Legacy
again I haven't opened it haven't looked
at
anything in this art book yet other than
what you know the few things they showed
early I didn't even look at the leaks
like I read about the leaks and stuff
man okay that is too cool
too cool thank you guys thank you guys
uh over at WB for sending that man I'm
gonna have to find a good place for all
of these things man all of these